We studied today about
Exponential functions
Exponential growth.
The following exponential function
y equals 3 x.
Note that
The independent variable x
The exponent is in this function.
Draw a table that shows
How fast exponential growth of this function and then you can draw the function curve.
The first column values ​​x, and the second values ​​are y.
The values ​​of x are negative 4,
Negative 3, Negative 2, 0, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
Calculate y values ​​through
Compensation for the x value in the function.
If x equals minus 4, y is equal to 3 as negative 4
And equal 1 to 3 s4.
3S 3 equals 27, 3 hits equals 81.
If, y equals 1 on 81.
When x is equal to minus 3, y is equal
3 Asalab 3.
And equal 1 to 3 s 3
Is equal to 1 on 27.
Note that the value of y
Became bigger.
If x equals minus 2, y is equal to 3 ms negative 2
And equal 1 to 3 squared, ie 1 on 9.
When x is equal to 0, y is equal to 3 s 0
Equal to 1.
3 AS 1
Equals 3.
3 AS 2
Equals 9.
3 S 3 equals 27.
3S4 equals 81.
3 S 5 equals 243.
Draw a curve for these values ​​to notice
How fast y values ​​increase.
Draw the horizontal axis x
The vertical axis y.
Let me do it in increments of 5, because I
You really want to get the general shape of the graph here.
So let me draw a straight line.
Suppose that this is 5, 10, 15.
In fact, I will not get 81 this way.
I want to get 81
Well, that's good enough.
Let me draw it a little differently
Of which I drew.
Note that all y values ​​are positive
You may notice, are positive values ​​because I have
Because the foundation is positive.
So let me draw it like that.
Good enough.
The coordinates of the vertical axis are 10, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80.
This is 80 there.
This is 10.
This is 30.
These will be good for rounding.
The coordinates of the horizontal axis are
This is a positive 5 here.
In fact, let me hold it a bit more.
Negative 1, Negative 2, Negative 3
Negative 4.
1, 2, 3, and 4.
If x is equal to 0, y is equal to 1.
Draw the point here.
Somewhere out there.
When x is equal to 1, y equals 3,
Draw this point almost here.
If x equals 2, y equals 9
Almost here.
When x equals 3, y equals 27
If x is equal to 4, y is equal to 81, and this is the point here.
Note that the y value has increased significantly.
If x is equal to 5, y equals 243, ie
The value of y increased much more.
If x is negative, y is lower
Even at minus 1, we are at 1/9.
And approaching 0.
The higher the negative x values
Y values ​​are closer than zero
Negative A, 3 to minus a million, we are
But it will not reach 0.
When the value of x is equal
Negative infinity, the curve is close to zero,
Then it starts to rise slowly
Then suddenly rises dramatically
The closer to the positive values.
Numbers, we will explode.
And continues to rise.
At an increasing rate.
So the idea here is just to show you that
The function is really exponential, really exciting.
There are exponential functions where exponential growth is much faster
y equals x x.
But the exponential growth of this function
Also very fast.
They moved on to the next issue
For exponential functions.
Someone sent a message to 10 people
In the first week.
He asked everyone who received the message
Send it to
10 other people.
To be bad luck, your hair will fall down, and
You will marry a frog, or anything else.
Then send everyone the message
To 10 other people
In the second week.
It is to 10 other people.
So every one of these 10 originals sent 10
This means that 100 people
Receive the message.
Each of those 10 sent 10, so that 100
Sent messages.
So, in the first week, 10 people received the message.
In the second week 100 people.
In the third week
Each of the 100 people must send the message
To 10 people.
A series of messages.
So, the total number of people who received the message until the third week is 1000.
So, the general rule is
Per week n
How many people received the message?
Week n equals 10 ms
The number of persons
Who received the message.
For example, how many people received the message until the sixth week?
How many people will receive this message?
10 AS 6
Equals 1 million people.
One million people will receive this letter at 6
Weeks, only by sending 10 messages each.
If everyone sends the message
To 10 people.
But if you do, if every 10 people sent you too
Send to 10 people and so on and so forth, by
Week Six You will have a million people.
Until the ninth week, the number of people is one billion.
And so on
You have finished the matter.
I'll see you in the next video.